things
got real as submit faces parents
once again to try to get them to accept
his relationship
with jenny seen by that cookie i tried
committing suicide plus i spoke with
jenny and she addressed one of submits
parents major concerns
as they grow old around the same time as
she will who will cement choose to take
care of
well he he has another he has a younger
brother
that lives there also and so
his younger brother can take on that
responsibility
hey 90 day fans fam it's melissa
the other way is officially back and
some of the couples faced
their most challenging moments yet
i look over at romano's mom and she's
looking directly at the ground
i can tell that she's embarrassed that
she's hurt by this announcement
it was a pretty rough night for armando
and kenneth and
armando's mom did share her thoughts on
their engagement
which we'll get to in just a moment but
first
let me give you the latest on submit and
jenny
during this episode jenny's time in
india
is running out and in order for her to
stay
she and submit have to get married but
in order for them to get married they
need submits parents approval
my heart was pounding i closer to my
parents house i get more nervous
so after keeping his distance for a
while
due to their last argument over jenny
samid confronted his mom
and dad [ __ ]
be
jenny after all of this drama he would
up until this point it seemed as if his
parents
just weren't going to budge but then
cement shared how much pain he suffered
from being pressured by them
to live life on their terms and that's
when you started to see them come around
to the idea
just a bit more
stress
i was the one who was suffering
[Music]
think about it
that sounds like progress now when it
comes to whether or not they're
actually going to allow him to marry
jenny
that's still on the table as of right
now his dad
says only time will tell
well smith met up with jenny after
leaving his parents
and he told her that he doesn't consider
their conversation a
win but it's definitely a step forward
so kind of you can say that's the kind
of kind of acceptance
not 100 percent it's just
more of an understanding kind of kind of
understanding
okay what about the marriage part i
don't know what's gonna happen
i'm so worried because a lot rides on
submits parents approving of our
marriage
if they block it then i'll have to leave
india
and that could ruin our relationship so
are you sure that i'm who you want to be
with yeah i'm sure
you know we can think whatever we want
about this relationship
but one thing is obvious cement loves
jenny
enough to go through all of this drama
and chaos with his family
i spoke to jenny a few weeks ago and she
admitted that she knows
she's a lucky woman she also responded
to submits parents concerns
about her growing gold at the same time
as
they will well he he has another he has
a younger brother
that lives there uh also and so
his younger brother can take on that
responsibility but
submit will be there too uh it's not
going to work out like that
what they're worried about is just not
going to happen i'm
certainly not going to keep him away
from his family
and if they need him he will be with
them
and i will love him i'm not gonna stop
him
hey all right well moving on to
armando taking kenneth to meet his
family
for the first time
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
kenneth's introduction to armando's
family
it was a bit awkward to say the least
it's definitely a new situation for
armando's family to get used to
and it didn't help that kenneth is not
very fluent
in spanish so they all sat around the
fire
quiet for a good little minute
i don't know what to say
[Music]
even though i'm physically here i'm just
kind of lost in my own head
i just don't know what to say or how to
in front of family with kenny here
and i'm worried about my dad
okay i just feel like he's trying to
stay in the house
to avoid us just to refresh your memory
out of armando's family his dad is
probably the one who took the news of
his relationship with
kenny the worse but luckily
his feelings about the situation didn't
stop him
from coming out to say hello to his son
[Music]
[Music]
well if that was a bit difficult for you
to watch
just wait until they get back to the
rest of the family
yesterday
look i admire armando's courage
but this did shock me i'm guessing he
just wanted to go ahead and lay
everything out there immediately
i'm looking around i see the shock
and the silence is like forever
foreign well here's how armando's mom
felt about it
in a perfect world this would have been
a happy conversation but it was
nice to see that although armando's
family
was shocked they still didn't dismiss
the news
they hope we're invited that
[Music]
a
another hurdle to climb but
i'm proud of armando for taking the
steps to live the life of
his dreams whether the people around him
agree with it or not that takes
guts all right well still to come from
the other way i'm excited about it
me and jihoon officially got married on
paper
but i really want to have this big
wedding
devin's wedding ceremony might not go as
she planned
[Music]
and ariela unexpectedly goes under the
knife to give birth
[Music]
that's intense all right 90 day fans fam
make sure you stick with et to stay
updated on
all the latest news from the 90 day
universe
i'll see you next time
you